fine anyway start all right everybody
welcome to another business Q&A as we
play a game of league of legends I'm
excited to be here this would be a fun
day we've got my usual co-host I feel
like I can't say co-host is your anymore
cuz it was a big thing yesterday but my
co-host Rishi cut TV welcome back I'm
the co-host of your how you doing I'm
great how are you doing Evan good i've
got my I believe mug drinking some tea
got some eggs Alex bunch of stuff yeah
what's in your cup today on national
coffee day well the plan is to go to
Krispy Kreme because Krispy Kreme is
offering everybody a free coffee and
donut today even without a purchase so
there you go Wow I know and this is not
a sponsored video Wow yeah yeah Chrissy
cream is hijacking the stream rhymes too
I ya know so we got Jay rise or setting
up a game i want to give a quick
shout-out to our live you got good meets
nice whoever good meets gneisses welcome
aboard relaxing sleep Station Zeno Rishi
Jen so much i love it i love there's all
kinds of china already happening in the
live stream its grapes I know I'll
absolutely taken it back yeah Zeno's
same lots of folks here must be a new
record yeah hey every every day we're
breaking records man every day oh okay I
guess I'm to talk about tomorrow
tomorrow I have a doctor's appointment
in the morning at seven-thirty and I
don't know if I'm gonna be back in time
for this mm so we'll have that what if
we leave there we can meet we can either
cancel it or we can play it by ear
because I know you have to wake up
really reach it to get here and so let's
think about it while we play what we
want to do for tomorrow okay yeah let us
know on the chat what you guys want
let's invite the doctor to play LOL with
us alright well while we get a game set
up let's uh let's get into some
questions great let's do it okay first
question today come from Bradley Bradley
and yeah and actually I feel like we've
had a question from Bradley daily before
recently so hey Bradley and he's asking
i was wondering how you make sure that
you are hiring someone who is truly
hardworking and a great employee rather
than someone who says that they are a
great employee that never lived up to
the expectations no I have a lot to say
husband but I'm excited that you're
really first absolutely i mean you know
if i may go a little bit on a rant oh
wow the rishi Reds all right well I'm
just realizing because I've also
recently been involved in the hiring
process and interviewing and things like
that and and i'm i'm actually on the
side of being interviewed and you know
that whole process which i haven't
actually been doing that i haven't done
that in a while but i was just thinking
about and this is kind of like more
rishi cup TV message in terms of like
really owning who you are and embracing
who you are and you know sharing from
that place and i was thinking about how
many different things we've set up
whether it's education or the job
workforce where we're always constantly
teaching people how to share so that
they can press not share on just who
they are i think even today I mean you
have this amazing now I've got
I find it but it was a quote about you
know don't try to impress people V you
and then the right people are going to
love you do you remember or not love you
but you said it way better but the point
is is like we're just we're just
creating I think the system even the
hiring system is set up in such a way
where you're you're always taught to
just impress instead of just being you
and and offering what you actually who
you are and I understand why it is the
way it is because you know we live in a
world where you know getting a job is
important if you know so you want to put
your best foot forward there's nothing
wrong with that but I think there's a
little bit of this where the system is
messed up where people can't just be
honest even in their applications or be
honest in their interviewing process
because they're more worried about
trying to tell you what you want to hear
instead of just being who you are and
believing that that is enough and I get
that you know you have to have skills to
do things and all of that but did you
hear what I'm saying Evan it's just like
whether it's hiring or whether it's
applying for college and university or
whatever people get wrapped up in how
can I tell you what you want to hear
instead of how could I just be me and
and and that be enough and so I think
that's part of why you get people like
Bradley who say well I've hired someone
and they aren't who they were on paper
because you know it becomes more about
impressing out of the desperation to get
the work that it does about being who
you are so I think it's a greater
problem that I have I'm a little bit
passionate about
right now we're we're not making it okay
for people to just basically they are
that's my rant the Rishi rant Rishi goes
on I like it well before I answer I've
got Timo jungle super excited the J
reyez pantheon mid experiment continues
I hope to be able to actually get a full
game in today and make Martin proud and
test out some of the things he told me
so we're gonna we're gonna see how thank
you and we look my list of things I'm
supposed to do I wrote it down to my
notepad here so I have in front of me um
yeah I think the hiring process is
broken i think it's it's not very
efficient i think a lot of it stems from
Rishi's points to in that people are
just trying to get the job and you're
always trying to impress and I I think
as an employer it sucks because you know
we really want to find the right people
and to have people who are really taking
it seriously really really sucks my
client is not loading let me just see
what's going on here there we go okay I
mean um first of all I think as an
employer if you want to track the right
people then you need to put what you
stand for in the in the job description
what you're all about so when I'm hiring
somebody it'll be you know i'm looking
for a belief programmer hashtag believe
programmer and then I explain what that
means and I put that in in the
description and I want people to love
her to hate it I want people to see it
and say man that's awesome that's this
is for me or this is really stupid you
know I'm just a programmer I don't care
about this mission so people start to
self eliminate immediately and you also
start attracting the right people's that
if there was a program that was on the
fence between going with me and somebody
else this could make the difference for
them so that's the start next in it in a
job description I will make it one long
boring
ugly paragraph to make it difficult to
read intentionally because I need the
people on my team to be detail-oriented
because I'm not a lot of times so and in
the middle somewhere there i will post
two questions so i'll post a bunch of
texts and then i'll post a question like
in the first line of your response tell
me how many YouTube fans I have our
youtube subscribers i have in the first
line and then i'll go on to talk about
the job and then i'll come back to say
in the second line of your application
tell me why you believe in entrepreneurs
and then i'll continue on with the rest
of the text so I want to make it hard
intentionally to find those questions
and I'm testing what did they even read
the job post because most people don't
even read the job which is sad oh I
would say eighty percent seven if I'm
going through this you know right now
with with Toronto dance salsa and hiring
somebody seventy five to eighty percent
of people do not even read the job post
and don't answer the question so they
lead off with their just standard copy
and paste resume and that sucks right
that is not what like you're wasting my
time if you have not bothered to read my
job I'd why should I bother reading your
application and it's so easy to copy and
paste like I'll programmer job okay
there's 30 programming jobs i'm going to
apply to all of them and just see who
bites but on my side as an employer I
have to read your thing right and so
you've put in two seconds of work and it
takes me a couple minutes each time at
least to read it and you know a couple
minutes may not sound like a lot but you
multiply that out by you know 100 people
applying that's you know three four
hundred minutes it's hours of time being
wasted no one of our players is not in
the game it's
sad so that's the first part like that
are running eliminates with the job ad
talking about your values and then with
with the question being in there you can
see the people follow instructions or
not right are they actually reading so
if you actually took the time to read my
job Adhanom not you're going to take the
time to read your application otherwise
forget about it next to see if they can
actually but can they follow the
instructions right I said in the first
line do this in the second I do that did
they actually follow that or did to do
it out of order it requires just a tiny
bit of ingenuity because I'm asking tell
me how many subscribers i have on my
youtube channel you'd be surprised by
how many people write back and they say
what's your youtube channel and i'm
happy to tell you how many subscribers
you have like my type Evan Carmichael
you tune and you'll find it right this
is this enough that difficult but you
know and it's and somebody who I want to
hire in an entrepreneurial venture is
someone who can you know be creative and
get the job done right and do the work
so if you don't have enough creativity
to think about how to find out what my
youtube channel is we're probably not
going to be a good fit together and then
it's also the qualitative answer that
was there around why do you believe in
entrepreneurs I want someone who
actually carries with entrepreneurs they
don't see it as another job but they
love the mission and I want to see you
some kind of story I don't care about
their English necessarily i don't care i
mean the pen school i'm hiring if i'm
hiring a programmer i think is another
challenge of the industry is if i'm
hiring a programmer all i need to care
about is that they can communicate with
me I don't need to hire somebody who
okay I don't need to hire somebody who
who was a wordsmith I'm not looking for
Shakespeare I'm looking for someone who
can write code so as long as I can
understand what they're all about then
the
that's a win so I look at what why do
they want to help entrepreneurs what do
they love about it and the ones that you
know write an answer that I get
emotionally attached to those are the
people that I want to make a connection
with and learn more about all of this is
before ever meeting anybody and I've
already weeded out you know ninety
percent plus of the candidates who want
to potentially work for me the next
thing I do is not a job interview I'm
not a big fan of job interviews
especially early on in the process I
think it's too easy to fake and I think
it tests the wrong skills like
somebody's ability to do well in a job
interview has very little with their
ability typically to do the job that I'm
asking them to do or in most cases right
if I'm hiring a if I'm hiring a dance
teacher if I'm hiring a programmer if
I'm hiring a writer like a writer needs
to write a writer doesn't need to ace a
job interview right so it's different
yes his communication skills but it's
different kinds of communication skills
and so I think people often are just
testing for the wrong thing and so you
know it bothers me so so what I do is I
set up a trial job like for all the
people who that pass those first
qualifications you know they read the
job description they filled it up
properly they have a reason for liking
entrepreneurs their passion about you
know the job that's at hand then I hire
people on a trial job I give them a job
that I think should take about two hours
and is relevant to the task that they
have to do so if it was a programmer
would give them a programming job if
it's a writer i would say hey write
write a paragraph or write write me a
youtube description or whatever it is
just some small sample the kind of work
that they would be doing for me i give
them a job that i think will take two
hours but I give them five hours to do
it one I do it because I want to see a
lot of my team and my
this is remote so I don't work with them
face-to-face in the same office and so I
want to see if somebody's ripping me off
I want to see if somebody's milking home
anybody who just does who takes the full
five hours it's probably someone I'm not
going to hire because I feel like
they're trying to take advantage of the
situation or they're just a really slow
worker which isn't a good fit for what I
want at my business either team is
fighting team is dying not great so I'll
give them a trial job and I'll see who
does well I test who does an actually
good job on that trial job like did they
get the results that we were looking for
I test how is it communication with me
like are they asking smart questions do
we work well together are they you know
is it fun interacting with them and the
most important thing probably I'm
looking for is I want someone to do
something a little bit out of the
ordinary looking for someone to allow me
with something all the people that I've
hired have wowed me in some way on that
trial job so they didn't just do what I
asked him to do but they did a little
bit more so as an example Sandra who are
hired to do a lot of them she's my
personal assistant books a lot of my
meetings and also does a lot of the
YouTube responses in the comment she you
know the trial job was ok guys I hired I
don't know 10 people to do this spent
five hours in the comments and i want
you to respond to 20 comments now
responded 20 common shouldn't take five
hours she did it in while i want to say
45 minutes or so um but then didn't just
do 20 she did 30 right like way above
what I asked and I showed a lotta love
in the comment so she was the no-brainer
easy decision of who I'm gonna hire for
this Christina I would hired what's that
you look at here I love it when I hired
Sam christina was my video editor it was
the same thing like she did the job in
less time and she did what I asked of
making a video but then she also said
you know I had another idea for another
way you could take it and she did her
own version of the video so she gave me
two options I liked her version better
and so you know I hired her that's been
three years ish um so I would much
rather have people prove themselves to
their work then in an interview i think
an interview can can't help at some
point but I'd much rather people show
off what they can do because talk is
pretty cheap and I want to see what the
ball can't deliver and it allows people
I found some great people on my team
I've got a team of misfits I got a team
of some people some people would never
hire these people because they may not
interview well Mike is all the typical
these are amazing hard-working people
who because they don't interview well
don't get the great jobs that you know
they could potentially get so I'm
forming it and that I have a better
hiring process but yeah that that's what
I would go through I think the way most
companies hire is just broken doesn't
work and this is the best way that least
I found for my business on how to make
it work well I love that and I for those
of you who want to review everything
Evan you said there is a video on his
channel called your hiring process is
broken and that will give you all that
great information if you'd like to
review it oh and and Evan I found this
the quote on us on your website don't
change so people will like you be
yourself and the right people will love
the real you and I I know that it's kind
of like more certain philosophical side
and then there's
a practical side of the hiring process
but like I truly believe I think the
hiring process was broken but i think
it's not just a hiring process it's like
all the systems that we've set up it
demand that you be someone other than
who you are so you can get the job or
get into college or whatever yeah and we
got some yeah buck very good don't think
you'd be coming from the other side as
somebody looking for a job looking for
Oh went in I didn't know it's my bed I
let my team down that one's good job um
yeah yeah I don't know how many people
on this team are looking for jobs but
but we all are in terms of trying to
impress the media and clients and you
know we want to get those deals the best
shot you have is doing is is being you
and that sounds stupid yeah you know
every time I've taken a deal with the
company and and didn't feel right about
it for whatever reason had this kind of
pit in my stomach that something is you
know just off then it's never worked out
it's never worked out for me I've always
been disappointed somehow like just look
good on paper you know great brand name
client but mm just we just couldn't work
together I died here but we got dragon
so it's good yeah and having the courage
to be yourself also helps you separate
yourself like I would rather go to an
interview with a client and and lose the
deal by being myself then get the deal
by being fake because that deals not
going to
it's not going to work out in the long
run and by being myself I'm much more
likely to attract the right kind of
clients and people who appreciate what I
have to say so right we got a comment
from good me tonight saying and tell
Evan to get a pink I'm i don't know if
it's too late now to tell you that Evan
but no it's not I it's on my list of
things thank you for the reminder is
that Martin watch I need that it's on my
list of things that I'm supposed to do
that Martin gave me maybe that is Martin
watching I do not get there it's not
what I do so I got a yes thank you thank
you guys thank you team I need to we
also get need to do that well we also
got some some people saying yeah we love
Sandra Santa does a great job from your
previous comments with her so just shut
out to test Andhra doing great doing a
great job nice all right making sure I'm
not missing anybody in the chat oh we
also had we also had da Mosta saying he
loved your hiring process and he started
implementing it himself and has really
just loved using it to uh to hire
freelancers and and so he had huge stuck
with that so that's great awesome I
still don't know who the master is but I
love that he's great um yeah I you know
what it may not be the perfect system
but but I did it because I found the
system that was most people using just
wasn't working
my team is dying everywhere I need to be
doing more to help I'm not doing enough
aid the other thing i might add to that
is I've often found that the people who
like be willing to be surprised I would
give the test job to basically anybody
who answered those questions properly um
but often the people who who I looked at
and and you might judge right like
there's still some judgment of their
their resume and what they wrote and
whether they have perfect English or not
and a bunch of other stuff I've often
been surprised by just giving people an
opportunity and so it's a low-risk
opportunity right you're just testing
something out on the small scale you're
given them up to five hours the worst
case scenarios and I paid by the way
like that five hours is paid i want to
it's a paid trial it's not just a ball
into your time that that worst case
scenarios i've spent five hours on
somebody paying them and they didn't
deliver anything but that's a pretty
it's a pretty low cost a low-risk way of
getting good people instead of thinking
about how much time you waste doing job
interviews and reading resumes and cover
letters in the typical process so there
may be a better way to do it but i
haven't found it yet cool and i just
want to make sure I put this in as well
we got a comment that says that oh and I
missed it so I'm gonna move on and then
I'll come back to that alright next
question comes from lizette Lysette says
she watched your video called seven
things that you can do to make more
money you got really motivated
by the video and so what what she did is
made 25 motivational and positive videos
she said she shared on Facebook she's
ready to make the most of YouTube by
uploading them to her channel and start
creating a brand for herself she's also
working yeah she's working to now be a
certified life coach and so she's pumped
up and her question is basically in
regards to her YouTube channel should
she upload all the previous videos
regardless of how long ago she recorded
them or should she focus on new material
only so yeah she just she wants to start
you know getting some momentum on
YouTube even before you know before she
gets to be this like expert life coach
she just wants to start you know so
great question I actually you know I
think again kind of going back to our
previous point you could decide not to
post the videos because they're older
and maybe not as professional not as
great because i know when i started
youtube you know my first video was
definitely not something that you know i
continue to grow and get better and so
you could say oh don't post those older
videos because they're not at the
quality but i think that people really
appreciate seeing your process and so i
think that you can build some nice
connection with your audience by posting
those older videos and allowing people
to see your process and maybe what you
want to do is make a make a video now
that's saying hey guys you know welcome
to my channel i'm going to start sharing
my process with you of my you know
exciting journey in my business and so
i'm going to start you know posting
videos from whenever you start it so
that people have some context as to why
you're posting the older videos and
anyway i think it would be a
great opportunity to invite your
audience on the journey with you and I
think people connect to that so I would
say go for it I like that we got a
YouTube question you know how much she
loves you too love it I'm all what we're
gonna go to tower I i bought a pink guys
i bought a pink I'm hopefully doing
Martin proud here i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go put it down let's go put it in there
in their jungle let me focus on this
because i don't usually do this so there
we go ok Martin be happy ok good um I
don't know how much even matters like I
i I'd like the journey you know like I
like being able to follow along I think
that's a good idea um I like the people
can look at my old videos and see the
growth on my channel I you know if I
look back at those videos I'm I'm
horrified you know like oh man so bad
those are just terrible terrible
terrible videos I gotta go back here um
but I liked it like I keep them up I
don't I don't delete them um I just I
think it's I think it's good to have him
there if I was starting my channel fresh
I don't know that I would go back and
delete I sorry go back and include the
new videos just coming in from scratch
but you know like with a YouTube channel
you're going to do it you're gonna have
so many videos that you will make over
time that it's just one of many so
mm-hmm whatever feels right I don't
think it's a big deal either way like
more important than then then doing it
is just making the decision moving on
because in the time that you like our
thinking about doing should I upload the
video and upload the video you could
have been uploading way more videos
already
so I think that's the most important
part just whatever you feel is right
there's no you know you don't need my
approval whatever you feel it's not
going to be a mistake if you do it I
don't do it just uh just make a decision
and start and be consistent that's going
to be the most important thing to
improve your game is being consistent
but I gotta know I gotta kill here's the
thing to Evan if you you you were saying
how those older videos of yours were I
don't each I think you should terrible
i'm not remembering what the words are
but but here's the thing like what's
fascinating is that the value of those
videos is it's like it might be look of
it the video and the music all might be
different but the value was the same I
enjoy watching this old video so you
know I know Gary v's also puts old old
videos still up from you know the
earlier days so i just i think that the
value kind of doesn't change and so i
think people appreciate the older videos
because they see that journey and and
the information is the same level of
value so I I don't know I pick it I
think it's cool yeah I think a lot of
the stuff that I've seen has always been
the same just my delivery is better the
contact is better the the value might be
delivered faster I'm still I'm still
like I I haven't deleted the videos I'm
still proud of the videos I like that
they're there but I look at them and
cringe because i know i could do so much
better
let all of us i'm sure you look at your
first video or if you're a singer you
look you know your first song or
whatever it is it's uh it might have a
look at you with that point but but it's
20 you know compared to your standards
now it's probably really bad but that's
okay doesn't mean you need to delete it
all right we've got some people giving
some comments on the game a relaxing
sleep station is saying oh no good needs
not just saying tell them to get blue
trinket oh yes that's Martin it's a
hundred percent Martin that's that's
that's my coach right there thank you i
know i need the SNT to upgrade i'm not
having a good game i don't know why this
is this is a subpar performance but we
are worried we're still in it we're
still in it what's the good news yeah
and previously I that was becoming eyes
I lost when I was looking for it he had
said earlier tell him to place his words
and use f keys more well I put my wore
down the pink and it's still there it's
still alive so hopefully I did a good
job on that one Jay rises having a crazy
game though he's 9 and 1 so oh wow he
arises he's saving this game he's saving
this game night oj oj so we've got a
question actually in the chat from
relaxing sleep station it was a
follow-up question from from yesterday
he asked about the collab do you
remember the question is ray about
youtuber collabing uh yes yes yeah the
bank video way whether to put your best
videos up or whatever right yeah right
exactly he said what I didn't specify
was can I use the same content on my
channel I've seen Evan have book reading
videos the Ryan Holliday the different
version same audio different footage
could I give the same
a different youtubers but different
video then also have these same videos
on my channel and I think that's pretty
straightforward yes I think that that's
totally okay I mean it's your content
you get to choose how you want to
deliver it and yeah I haven't any
thoughts on that I would just talk to
the youtuber first to see what they
think if they're okay with a the people
are expecting to be able to have you
know unique content and then you're
using it on their chant on your channel
too they might get they might not be
happy with that so as long as they're
good with it then I don't think it's a
big deal I wouldn't have a problem with
it if we were doing something together
but others might so just be careful of
that if you want to you know build and
keep a relationship some people are very
anal about those things and others
aren't so that's what I go great alright
next question comes from monigan and
mana don is asking on 20 years old doing
his undergraduate and computer science
and engineering but he's passionate
about filmmaking he's also a part of
this national level robotics contest and
he's struggling because he he says the
only thing that matters is that I do it
for his team he's not super excited
about continuing with the robotics but
he feels like if he if he is not in
continuous esteem that they're they're
going to suffer without him kind of
helping manage them so he's just kind of
torn because he says you know it's it's
a responsibility but I still love to
pursue filmmaking after i'm done with my
studies could you help me
he's really and at the end it's really
nice he says you you've been a huge
medium for inspiring me motivating me
and getting me out of the hardest
darkest periods of my life wow that's
pretty cool well yeah I I guess my
question 2mon Adonis is uh why did you
feel you have to not do you know why
does it have to be one or the other I
appreciate that you are to get out for
you're looking up for your team you know
you recognize that you contribute
valuable there and so you want to make
sure you're doing right by them but
still making is awesome and there's no
reason you can't start right now even in
your studies with the filmmaking and
studying that as well so at the end of
the day if that's what you're really
passionate about you should start doing
whatever you can to gain the knowledge
there and and I'm sure even your
computer science and engineering
background will help you with that in
some kind of really cool way oh my god
so he wants to he's saying he wants to
quit to go do filmmaking and he doesn't
want to let down his team well that's
why I'm wondering why there he feels is
a conflict critique him in this robotics
team and he's also doing a studies
anything I don't want to see his plan
would reduce his plan would be to do
still making after his study so he's not
saying he wants to quit on his studies
but he's just not really excited about
the robotic as much as he is filmmaking
so I think he just wants kind of
guidance as to how to start pursuing
filmmaking you know even though he's in
another field right now so what was the
part about letting down his team though
because he was going to leave them
yeah I think he's he's feeling not
passionate enough and so he said after
I'm not caring about it the robotics
national competitive team he said I'm
not caring about it but I have to do it
for my team they're not self managing
and they're made there may be a dense
I'm not involved okay so why not I agree
with reaching that at some point you
know you can start sooner just start
right it's important to start it's
important to build momentum for what
you're doing um i just kind of the kill
team was coming back guys chemo is
coming back yeah Oh timo as I said that
team was dying timo died just as I said
that I died very sad that's what I get
I'm not used to this order here okay
anyway this new build is giving me
anyway it's fine um start now right
tarisha's point find a way to start now
find a way to start small just start
well you know you want to be a filmmaker
start making films you just need a
camera go and start doing whether that
means you leave your team or not you
know I'm a big believer in starting
small and seeing if you can build
momentum in not just burning the boats
and going all in on something um but
it's gotta be you know your style how
you how you like going in on projects I
know some people have to go all in if
you've lost the love for what you're
doing you know at some point you have to
figure out when do you owe it to
yourself to do the right thing you know
like when do you owe it to yourself to
to just stop and no and yes maybe let
people down but the intention isn't to
hurt people it's doing what's best for
you
and at some point we get into those
situations whether we're sledding like
somebody will be let down but if you can
explain the process and what you really
want to do it's really hard to stop
somebody from money to pursue their
dreams I think about as an example when
when I sold my first business I didn't
want to sell you know it wasn't
something that I want to do I love the
business I love we were going I thought
we had a lot of upside a lot of
potential my business partners wanted to
get to California as a part of their
their dream and this was a path for them
to do it because the company buying us
would sponsor it's Canadian you can't
just up and move to California and the
company was going to sponsor them and so
it's hard for me to get in the way of
you know the dreams of the people around
me right and care is you know we
disagreed on it especially at the start
but at the end of the day by that honest
communication not by just fighting about
it but by talking about it we were able
to to get through and so you know your
friends will probably understand you
know at first he'll just think through
their own eyes and I go you know he's
leaving us and you know now what are we
gonna do we're screwed and you know I'm
gonna fail now because you left the team
and you know all this stuff and if you
can set them up for success if you can
maybe not just leave you know right away
but give them give them oh crap he does
a lot of damage holy cow that was crazy
that was nuts that was really unexpected
I died very sad I didn't think he would
do that much damage that was crazy um
and this comes this route it's had a lot
of times whether it's letting an
employee go whether it's talking to your
parents about how they want you to live
versus how you want to live you know the
career choices that you make whether
it's being in a relationship that isn't
supporting you
you will not do great things by not
being true to yourself so this is not
something that you're finding lasting in
German fulfillment in then you have to
get out and it doesn't mean that you do
it immediately doesn't mean that you
screw your friends over and they may
understand it they may not understand
but the intention at least is positive
so that's my advice there and yes start
small in the filmmaking start now start
right away get your camera go make a
film mm-hmm good luck huh looks like
we're gonna lose this game yeah yes at
times sad times X kijiji but right you
want another question now you're you're
ready for another one right ah i would
now we just lost better i don't want to
rush ok i don't want to rush mm-hmm so
uh ok Martin how did I do that was del
ism actually got better my late game got
better let's see what our final score
was I feel like I got a nested i get an
S oh I didn't even get an S wow that's
my that's my wow you should get an S so
I went seven and four seven kills four
deaths J reyez was 10 kills and three
deaths Wow the rest of our team was 13
kills and 30 deaths holy cow you guys
went 13 and 30 anyway so yes Martin I
need to get my pinks out i need to get
the blue ward sooner i need to play
around that was that was that was a bad
game for me well Martin says that you
got improvement in half of the points I
gave you so one hundred percent good
alright alright this doesn't feel great
but it's improvement
and you struggle as you improve so I
appreciate the push awesome well uh hi
what's the message of the day you want
to leave us with Rishi um being you cup
of BU yeah we've touched on that a
couple times in this episode mm-hmm I
love it holy okay so tomorrow what do
you guys want to do what do you want to
do is she I know you have to wake up
early and get to a place and I don't
know that I'm gonna be able to get on
time so I'm okay can you want or or its
I might be back I might not be back I
don't know how long I'm just gonna take
well what time you're saying what are
the options either do it later or do it
earlier what would the option no I can't
do it later it's either I get here on
time or I don't hey I get here on time
and we do it or or I don't and we don't
I'm ready whenever you a I'll be here
you know what maybe what I'll do is I
will I'll message you when i'm leaving
so i can page sometimes doctors go super
fast but sometimes i don't so i'll
message you when i'm leaving and then we
can i can give you a better indication
of he'll be back on time okay well don't
you worry because i'm already up anyway
so if it works I will be happy but if it
doesn't also you just need to make sure
you get this to get something hopeful
you're okay alright cool I'm awesome
well thank you guys for watching I hope
we answer some questions there that that
helped you we've got more live streams
coming up later in the day that you can
check out on the YouTube channel if this
is the last time I see you though enjoy
the rest of your day do something
amazing we go what 11 plus almost a full
day left to crush before in the week so
do it continue to believe or whatever
your one word is I will see you soon